stitch to your third takeaway which is
the colts they've won five out of six
now so this indie team is getting hot
what's coming together for them as they
just knocked off your patriots on
saturday night
well let me just tell you okay because
back when tony dungy had these guys they
were this finesse team they're gonna
pass the ball they have peyton manning
they're no longer a finesse team like
they used to be all right this offense
really sets the tone for this team and
those wide receivers whether
pittman and pascal these guys are big
they're physical they set the tone in
the run game they blocking the receipt
and they're blocking the dbs 20 yards
down the field quentin nelson he's
healthier this offense the line is
outstanding but what about baby i what
do i call him i call him a i call him uh
he's a smaller version of derrick henry
but faster you know what i mean this is
what you getting jonathan taylor he's
basically a smaller version of derek
henry but faster and i mean he's i mean
come on man this dude
if anybody's probably should be second
in mvp boat voting behind
um aaron rodgers it should be this guy i
mean he's come in he's established frank
wright's done a great deal committing to
running the football taking the ball out
of carson wins hands but
this offense is physical and the coats
are no longer a finesse team they're
going to run the ball down your throat
and i'm going to tell you something else
they got a pretty good special teams all
right ray ventron a former teammate of
mine he's their special teams
coordinator and this is the top special
teams in the nfl and they make a
difference every single week this is the
number one special teams team in the
league and they make a difference every
single week they're blocking a punt
blocking a field goal you know
making a big return they're doing
whatever they have to do frank wright
has done a great job down there we'll
see what happens with carson wentz in
the playoffs but he's done a great job
he sure has and he's taking a team that
got out of the gates very slow and has
developed in a loud environment with
everybody going you got to get rid of
wins this was a mistake rike sucks and
he's just prepared this season on the
fly and a big part of it's quinton
nelson coming back you mentioned that
offensive line who i think deserves a
ton of credit all five of them fisher
nelson pinter glewinsky and smith at
right tackle has been a top 10 right
tackle all season long but jonathan
taylor's over 1500 yards already we
still got three games left 17 touchdowns
that's a big number 17 touchdowns on the
ground over 100 yards five out of the
last six games over 150 yards three out
of the last six games so he's getting
hot down the stretch and with tom brady
having a bad game a really bad game on
sunday night it now comes down to i
agree with you i think you got aaron
rodgers and you got jonathan taylor and
if we didn't disrespect the running back
position like we do in this league
in my opinion it'd be jonathan taylor as
the mvp
yeah i mean think about him and he is
the most valuable player to his team
because without for sure and the coach
they look totally different without him
on the field and you should see the
relief from the defenses because now
defenses are afraid they're like oh my
god i got to deal with quentin nelson i
got to deal with this offensive line and
i got to deal with these big physical
wide receivers blocking us 20 yards down
the field and i got a deal we're trying
to bring jonathan taylor a guy that runs
4-3 at 230 pounds and all he has to do
is give you a stiff arm it's tough man
it's going to come down to carson wins i
like their defense they're not like
super physical they got linebackers that
run around kind of run around from
sideline to sideline darius leonard we
know that he's the top play-making
linebacker in the nfl
but it's gonna come down to carson wentz
and if they struggle running the
football because they'll have nine guys
on the line of scrimmage they're gonna
force carson wins to throw throw the
ball to beat him and we'll see what
happens it'll happen at some point he'll
have to and that defense 31 takeaways
first in the nfl that's what they do
plus 14 turnover differential that leads
the entire league by substantial margins
that's how they've won a bunch of these
games
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports